after Wolf of Wall Street there
definitely was an increase in violence
towards people with orphism and when I
say violently attacked I don't mean just
like picked up I'm talking about like
come out in an
ambulance hi my name is Lou make piece
I'm a Tik tocker and car salesman and
I've got dwarfism today I'm going to be
answering these questions from this
honesty
box what is dwarfism and what causes it
dwarfism is basically where your arms
and legs are a shorter length to an
average height person I haven't done
loads of research into it because I
think it's not the only thing that
defines me I think it's just something
that I've been born with and you just
kind of have to get on with it my mom's
average height my dad's average height
so I'm not too sure what happened but it
happens things do happen but it's how
you cope with them it's how you bounce
back and I'm here today being myself
living life and I'm loving it should
people bend down to talk to you right
this is a bit of a pet peeve I'm going
to be honest it's just it's one of those
things where we are adults at the end of
the day you can talk to us like we're a
person you only bend down if you're
talking to a kid I'm I'm not a kid at
the end of the day so it it is quite
demeaning but if anyone ever did it to
me I'm going to pull them up on it I'm
going to have to say something can you
say the word the word is
more of it's a derogatory term it's very
different to the word dwarfism because
dwarfism is the condition is the
slang word
of of that and if you're trying to
offend someone that's when you use the
word again I'm not saying use it
if I've been a to you but it's it's not
a nice word just like prick is not a
nice word but the thing is when prick
and is anyone could be a prick
but
only people with dwarfism can get
offended by the word and that's
it because it's it's a it's a dig at our
difference should we be remaking a film
called Snow White and and a seven
dwarves I've never personally watched
the film so I'm not too sure
on what the dwarves are actually used as
if you are going to go for that role of
playing a Snow White and the Seven
Dwarves all you're going to be doing is
going back in time where basically
anyone with dwarfism have got to have
roles as either elves or rolles as snow
Wier 7 dwarves or Lord of the Rings kind
of stuff there's loads of other sort of
films probably the worst being Wolf of
Wall stre Street after Wolf of Wall
Street there definitely was an increase
in violence towards people with dwarfism
thankfully I I've not been one of those
people but I have got mates that have
been in these situations in nightclubs
bars and they have been violently
attacked and when I say violently
attacked I don't mean just like picked
up I'm talking about like come out in an
ambulance quite concerning I'm I'm a bit
of a party boy myself so when I'm out
drinking just having a good time dancing
singing you know the the usual stuff
that a 23y old lad should be able to do
without being questioned or scared to do
yeah it's it's something I do have at
the back of my mind all the time why
would you do that like why would you be
violent towards someone that's not done
anything to you does dwarfism cause any
pain there's two kinds of pain with
dwarfism there's the emotional side and
there's the physical side
you you do have a lot of aches in your
arms and legs I do struggle to stand for
long periods of time also have arthritis
and aches in my joints yeah when I was
younger the pain was just unbearable I
used to cry like every night didn't know
what to do my mom being average height
she wasn't too sure on why the pains
were there the pains always stuck with
me but it's just one of those things
where you can't really get away with it
you can't get really away from the pain
like cuz it is a physical condition
condition which people don't really see
and I think that's why people think they
it's a they're able to take the Meck a
bit because people don't look at us like
disabled at the end of the day we are we
have got a disability we are aching on a
daily day basis but no one would make
fun of someone in a wheelchair but they
find it fine to make fun of someone with
dwarfism the emotional side of the pain
is probably the toughest more
excruciating cuz you can't walk out your
front door without having someone laugh
someone stare I don't think people
really understand what you go through on
a day today basis anytime I'm in a
supermarket anytime I'm in a public
space there someone looking someone
laughing someone staring someone taking
a like taking a video of me do you only
date other dwarves until I was 18 I
never actually knew anyone with dwarfism
so my whole life I was just kind of just
assuming I was going to be with an
average H person but when I was 18 I met
loads of people from my community and
that had dwarfism thought it was great
I'm so I was so glad that they was like
me because again all you see if you
don't know anyone with dwarfism all you
see on TV is them dressing up and I
don't dress like that I I'm a normal 23-
year old lad I like going out I like
partying like wearing new clothes
fashion everything so I didn't think
that other people with dwarfism was like
me I know that's really not a naive
thing to say from someone with dwarfism
but it's the way it's been portrayed so
when I met my M who actually has got
dwarfism to find someone like me great
chat S6 girl you know what I mean put
keeps me on my toes I couldn't have
asked for like better and that's why I'm
settled for life I couldn't I didn't
want any I don't want anyone else she's
such a positive light for me and just
keeps me going through it all um she's
been through similar situations to me
well on a day-to-day basis when we go
shopping in where we basically just get
stared at laughed at but I'm the one
that's bit more feisty I'll say stuff
but she's kind of said look there's no
point getting riled up and ruining our
day just let's just focus on the day and
just ignore it block it out don't look
at the comments just just live your life
like they're not there is all your
furniture smaller or custom
made now whoever wrote that question
obviously thinks I'm rich because if I
was going custom make everything in my
house yeah that'll cost an absolute
Fortune so no sadly it is not but also
I've been brought up in a a world where
everything is adapted to average high
people so if I make my home different
then I'm not going to be able to do
things in a public place or in a average
high person's house if you tailor your
life to your dwarfism you are going to
struggle you are going to because you're
going to there's always going to be a
situation that's never going to be
tailored for you cuz the world's not not
tailored around orphism there's always
going to be a situation where you're
going to go oh sorry I'm going to have
to sit out of this one because I can't
do it and I I'm I'm sorry I'm not going
to be that person to say I can't do it
Hugh Grant as an Umpa Luma
discuss so I actually went to see the
Wonka film last night really good film I
really liked the interpretation of it
the Giza that Willy Wonka is great as
well like honestly amazing job he done
Hugh Grant doing it amazing I thought
the best movement that someone's done in
a movie for a long time because at the
end of the day when R when R do wrote
that book I don't know if they were
supposed to be dwarfs or not but I think
he refer to them as little people but a
little person doesn't always have to be
someone with dwarfism I know there's
other people with dwarfism probably
screaming at the camera right now going
we've been robbed this is our
opportunity that's been taken away from
us look you you're better than that you
you don't like you're telling me the
best thing you can do in life is be a
Umpa lumper that's that's all you got
that's not no you're more than that
you're worth way more than that why
don't you play Wily Wonka don't go for
the Umpa Luma go go for the role of
Willy Wonka because there's nothing
there's nothing saying you can't will
you have kids and can you paral dwarfism
onto
them so because me and my Ms have got
dwarfism it's a 50% chance they'll have
the same condition as us aonl are and
then 25% they'll be average height and
then the other 25% is called double
dominant with the double dominant gene
it basically means your child won't
survive dwarfism will not you you just
want your kid to be healthy that's the
main thing so having that fear factor
that we have got a 25% chance of having
a kid with double dominant is it is a
worry Factor
but on the other hand we do want to have
our own kids
and I've noticed on social media as well
people say oh you're selfish for putting
your um for having kids and if you got
dwarfism but if you see me standing here
right now I don't know what's selfish
about it because I'm just like every one
of you like it's it's something that
people think it's more negative having
dwarfism than it actually is it's not
negative actually having dwarfism what's
negative is the people that make it a
negative so being having dwarfism isn't
actually a bad thing but also there's
25% they might be a a CH it which some
people might go oh would you want an a
baby at the end of the day as long as
they're healthy that's the main thing
what's the hardest thing you have to
deal with on a daily day basis just
walking out your front door and just
getting a just abuse straight away I
have got so much better since being 18
and that I've got so much better with
understanding it a little bit more and
understanding that I'm not the problem
they are when I was younger when I was a
kid when people used to stare and laugh
PE it didn't really phase me because I
didn't have the like I wasn't older so I
didn't really understand it but of
course the older you get you're going to
get more anxieties you're going to get
more stuff like that I think the hardest
thing to deal with is genuinely mental
health even now you're looking at me now
I'm on camera answering these questions
I'm not the most ident guy in the world
I try and betray myself as a confident
person but I'm not the most confident
person and I don't talk about my mental
health quite enough and things do really
get to me sometimes and it's talking
about it that's going to get you through
it at the end of the day and that's the
most important thing just to talk to the
people around you all the time keep them
updated and please please please don't
let anyone take your life away from you
the lowest point I've
had I did want to end things and thought
seriously about ending things planned it
out
and life's too precious and I've got too
much to lose too many good friends
family is great that was a low point for
me